[Music]
well the vegas golden knights
are back in action certainly a really
different start to this season with no
fans in attendance but
everybody's still pretty fired up
nonetheless yeah fans are no fans a win
trumps any kind of temporary setback
sports director chris matthews joining
us now with highlights
from the night season opener tonight
chris you know i think it really doesn't
it's probably fair to say
if it's only temporary fans will trade a
win watching at home on tv then a loss
sitting in the fortress
your vegas golden knights opening at
home with the anaheim ducks
first game at t-mobile and months in
fact the last time they played there
inside that building march 3rd vegas
jumped out to a quick
two-nothing lead goes by jonathan
marchessault and
tomas no [ __ ] but the duck's new answer
was tied 2-2 in the third when vegas
strikes captain mark stone
scores just 49 seconds into that third
period then vegas steps on the gas and
drives away the ducks max pacioretti
scores
they would add an empty netter as vegas
rolls to a 5-2 win
i mean so far so good i mean played well
tonight team
team did a good job really you know i
enjoyed myself out there it's a fun
group to be a part of
this is a tough building to play and
when we got 18 19 000 put
fans rocking it and if we would have
came out with a two to nothing lead
roof might have blown off this place all
right fun thing about this
truncated season lots of games over the
next four months vegas anaheim back on
the ice saturday
and the knights will debut those sharp
looking gold
jerseys so you'll see those for the very
first time more on the game coming up
in sports